monsieur le ministre la loi
d'orientation des mobilités de 2019 a
précisé un objectif de doublement de la
part modale du transport ferroviaire
dans les grands pôles urbains depuis les
annonces de succèdent celle du président
de la République pour le lancement des
RER métropolitains suivi par un plan de
développement du ferrovia inédit doté de
100 milliards d'euros d'ici 2040
et enfin cette semaine monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé une dotation
de 8,6 milliards d'euros pour les
contrats de plans et ta région pour 2023
2027 les deux tiers de cette enveloppe
iront aux infrastructures ferroviaires
et aux transports publics alors qu'il
faut inciter les Français à utiliser des
transports décarbonés et multiplier les
mobilités propres il est indispensable
que tous les territoires bénéficient
d'un réseau de transport performants et
adapté à notre temps ce réseau doit
s'inscrire dans un projet de territoire
consensuel et respectueux des
collectivités des usagers et des
riverains prenant en compte les
contraintes environnementales aussi
Monsieur le Ministre les projets pensés
presque au siècle dernier sont-ils
encore pertinents en Île-de-France par
exemple et on est ainsi du Tzen conçu il
y a 15 ans pour lequel une étude
d'impact environnementale sur le
nécessaire je parle de ma
circonscription mais le sujet est bien
présent dans nos territoires vos
annonces sur le lion Turin la semaine
passée n'attend plus qu'une réponse de
la région aura
dans cette même région il a aussi le
sujet de Clermont Paris nécessaire au
désenclavement de certaines communes ou
agglomérations à l'heure où les
négociations l'État et la région vont
débuter pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre
nous dire quel est l'évolution des
moyens consacrés au sein des contrats en
région les modalités de mise en œuvre
des financements ainsi que ainsi que
leur calendrier leur articulations avec
l'enveloppe des 100 milliards annoncés
enfin comment comptez-vous intégrer
pleinement les critères environnementaux
dans ces projets en créant une clause de
revoyure et révaluer ainsi des projets
anciens qui ne seraient plus adaptés je
vous en remercie